bâle bonjou base hot tout bon jour
caroline ventura alors vous êtes membre
de l'association notre histoire caraïbes
vous êtes venu nous parler de ce matin
de foyal 350 dont vous êtes la chef de
projet pour cette association de notre
histoire qui arrive alors il s'agit de
commémorer les 350 ans donc de fort
royal qui est aussi appelée foyal donc
une transformation une sorte de créole
isme de fort royal foyal en centre de la
ville de fort de france donc ça tout ça
a commencé en mars dernier 1 avec un
cycle de conférences et de débats
on s'en souvient nous avions reçu
gilbert pago l'historien gilbert pago
également président d'ailleurs de cette
association de notre histoire caraïbes
qui était venu nous nous en parler
puisqu'il faisait une conférence le 21
mars précisément sur nes ans ses
premiers pas de foyal et puis entre
temps depuis jusqu'au moins de doute il
ya eu une série de manifestations de
toutes sortes d'ailleurs y compris par
exemple ce voile céréens qui a lu dans
les rues de 2,2 fois yal de fort de
france au mois d'août alors caroline
ventura évidemment on va pas refaire le
jazz de toutes ces manifestations mais
quelle est la ou les deux manifestations
qui vous vous ont le plus marqué au
cours de deux justement de cette période
entre mars et août derniers les les deux
manifestations et qui m'ont le plus
marqué sont là la conférence du 22 mai
faites par gilbert pago qui est la
première que nous avons fait dans la rue
et donc avec bien sûr toujours le petit
risque de pluie et une très belle
conférence belle introduction le sujet
parfaitement mené d'ailleurs nos
conférences sont tous disponibles sur
youtube on ne les mettons en ligne les
capitons et nous les mettons en ligne
pour que ceux qui n'ont pas pu venir
puissent quand même en profiter
donc il faut pas plus violent 300 à 350
et ça marche et la chaîne s'appelle
notre histoire caraïbes et donc c'était
une très très belle conférence et c'est
le fait de la fer dans la rue est de
voir effectivement que et c'est notre
objectif
donc les gens viennent ceux qui en ont
entendu parler viennent et puis on a
aussi des badauds
des gens qui parce qu'ils s'arrêtent et
qui reste écouter et c'est ça et je
trouve que ça illustre bien l'état
d'esprit de ce programme à savoir
permettre à tout le monde
d'entendre de s'approprier de découvrir
l'histoire de la martinique alors nous
parlons de fort de france parce que
c'est l'occasion
mais il s'agit bien de l'histoire de
lille comment enfin comment les
communautés se sont installés les fins
comment les administrations là on a
parlé d'histoire militaire
on parlera d'histoire portuaire et puis
la deuxième manifestation qui m'a aussi
beaucoup marqué c'est le grand saut elle
sert et que nous avons fait dans les
rues de fort de france et ce qui était
absolument impressionnant pour ceux qui
seraient pas ou qui viennent de
débarquer en martinique soit le serrer
ses courses poursuites et un cache cache
c'est le terme c'est le terme en créole
pour cache cache et puis ça désigne les
jeux d'enfants général et c'était
vraiment l'état d'esprit amener les gens
à se promener dans fort de france
en levant le nez en s'interrogeant et
nous avons eu près de 200 participants
200 participants c'était pendant le mois
d'août
et c'est ça a été notre grande
satisfaction de voir que ça intéresse
vraiment la population les et ça c'est
aussi le l'enjeu pour nous a fouillés à
on parle d'histoire on parle de culture
on parle de martinique et et on a un
très très gros retour de la population
les gens sont très intéressés
oui alors cessé alors peut-être selon
les manifestations vous n'avez pas
toujours le même nombre mais y compris
par exemple les conférences justement
les conférences oui oui oui nous avons
un signal
oui oui nous avons aussi beaucoup de
monde et nous avons eu l'occasion
justement de refuser des gens parce que
au bout d'un moment la laisse à la
capacité d'accueil des salles étaient
insuffisantes et c'est là vraiment la
raison pour laquelle nous souhaitons
faire les conférences dans la rue avec
tous les défis techniques logistiques
que ça représente c'est de pouvoir dire
voilà enfin venez comme vous êtes et
venez parce que nous avons des choses à
dire et vous avez des choses à entendre
et donc ce serait dommage qu'on soit
embêté par des problèmes de place alors
donc tout ça est évidemment fait en
partenariat avec la ville de fort de
france est donc l'objectif initial de ce
programme
de cette commémoration organisée par
l'association notre histoire caraïbes
c'est vous le disais justement de bien
permettre à la population pas seulement
feuilles à l'aise
évidemment elle avant tout peut-être ou
surtout met donc à la population
martiniquaise de manière générale de
s'immerger dans son histoire et de
redécouvrir cette histoire à travers des
formats différents donc ça c'est valable
pour l'ensemble de l'histoire de la
martinique mais là en l'occurrence pour
donc ses 350 ans d'existence de fort de
france alors quelques mots avant de la
dernière en date
il s'agissait donc en partenariat avec
ciné ou les deux de donner à découvrir
un document ou en tout cas des
informations par rapport à des
trouvailles de fouilles qui ont eu lieu
dans fort-de-france des fouilles
foyalaise wipi savait que l'historien
benoît enfin le oui et le recours à
quelques en fait à chaque fois que l'on
construit un bâtiment
il ya des procédures dites de fouilles
préventives quand on découvre des
commandites des restes et à partir de là
bas à chaque construction de bâtiments
de grands bâtiments pense au palais de
justice on pense au haut commissariat
avait donc des campagnes de fouilles ont
été menées donc benoît partager avec
nous les découvertes qui ont été faites
alors certaines concerne bien sûr la
période coloniale
mais d'autres d'autres résultats de
fouilles amener des informations sur
justement la période précoloniale et les
amérindiens alors qu'arles une ventura
notre histoire caraïbes parle d'un temps
fort quand même à venir puisque vous
présentiez comme la semaine du 3 au 10
octobre donc la semaine prochaine comme
celle de la période phare de cette
commémoration
alors là encore conférences
représentations théâtrales un musique
classique et religieuse spectacle de
lumière dans la baie de fort de france
il ya tout un programme donc là ça y est
ça repart pour quasiment tout le mois
d'octobre et jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin
d'année alors le programme repart
effectivement avec des manifestations
d'octobre à la fin de l'année et nous
avons le temps fort qui est du 3 au 12
11 octobre avec effectivement une
intensification des manifestations
puisque la date anniversaire de la
création de fort de france est le 3
octobre
donc nous commençons avec un spectacle
de colette césaire au théâtre aimé
césaire nous enchaînons avec une
conférence sur le port sur l'histoire de
fort de france entre quevilly portuaire
nous ce sera vendredi 4 à ces vendredis
4 et le 5 nous avons aussi une belle
représentation de la troupe moon s'en
mêler aides marian mateus que nous
faisons venir de paris sur le discours
sur le colonialisme donc toujours au
théâtre aimé césaire
it's you samedi 5 5 ans l'accord le 8
nous parlons généalogie voilà ex
esclaves ergis d'individualités à fort
de france ce serait anthropique atrium
voilà avec eux
un conférence de la marina voilà c'est
ça la section qui saute voilà alors
comme on n'a pas beaucoup de temps on
pourra pas évidemment faire tout en
détail tout le programme et nous y
reviendrons dans nos différents et le
programme est disponible sur facebook
voilà facebook pour pour terminer car
l'une ventura un mot sur les
établissements scolaires aussi parce que
vous vous y êtes vous allé également
vous proposer à des élèves notamment des
ateliers ludiques autour de l'histoire
ça c'est alors ce format là c'est une
discussion que nous avons un projet que
nous menons avec canopée pour pouvoir
utiliser des outils qu'ils déploient
autour des dd comment dire des qr codes
et des balades
enfin des courses enfin pas cours soit
course découverte et c'est comme ça que
nous souhaitons justement proposé aux
élèves en établissement parce qu'ils ont
des outils pour ça et en leur montrant
un exemple de s'approprier eux aussi
leur environnement et leur histoire de
façon ludique
alors on a parlé des conférences devait
donner quelques exemples
et il ya toujours aussi on termine là
dessus cette idée d'aller dans la rue
d'être en plein air au plus près de la
population et donc il y aura également
une exposition photos en plein air sur
le patrimoine faut y aller oui et puis
encore un rallye dans les rues de fort
de france à venir la non non lieu oui
c'est bien laurent salsé l'expo photo
pour l'expo photo le ce que nous
souhaitons faire justement c'est encore
un format différent c'est pas une
conférence et un spectacle met donc à
travers l'art amener les gens à se
réapproprier et retrouver le lien qu'on
peut avoir avec un patrimoine
c'est toujours compliqué quand on vit
quelque part puisqu'on passe à côté on
se rend plus vraiment content et
l'objectif de travailler avec des
artistes c'est justement de pouvoir
changer le regard des gens sur leur
patrimoine et ceux qui les entourent
très bien merci car une ventura de nous
avoir donné donc quelques précisions sur
la deuxième partie de ce programme des
lacs envers nos rations des 350 ans donc
de fort royal fort de france
donc on a dit prochain rendez vous le 3
octobre notamment théâtre aimé césaire
avec cette balade poétique autour du
cahier d'un retour au pays natal d'aimé
césaire avec une
tentation de colette césaire tout ça à
mener donc par notre histoire caraïbes
et foyal 350 bonne journée à tous 6